[Music]
dakota is with us to start this hour in
san antonio hi dakota how are you
hi i'm good thank you so much for taking
my call sure what's up so i wanted to
see if i could get a little bit of
guidance from y'all um i
live with my boyfriend and we have a
baby together
um but we do not have our finances
combined um i bring debt into our
relationship he does not have any debt
um so i'm currently working on the baby
steps um using the snowball and um have
been trying to knock that out but we do
have quite a few shared finances um like
we pay for my 50 50 for my daughter's
daycare 50 50 for rent groceries all
that stuff so we're constantly like been
mowing or writing each other checks or
things like that to reimburse
and so i was just going to see do you
recommend continuing to keep our
finances separate until i knock out the
rest of our debt of my debt or should we
go ahead and combine them to make our
everyday expenses
easier so dakota why don't y'all just
get married
um because i
have a lot of guilt about having the
debt and i want to knock it out before
we get married
so you're waiting for marriage to pay
off your debt
yes okay
i would encoura i would encourage you i
would not wait i wouldn't wait and i
would encourage people
who want to get married not to they
don't have to wait i think even having a
baby you don't need to wait to have a
baby until you're debt-free uh that this
debt i wouldn't say i think that that's
a
that's kind of a separate thing i know
what what makes you feel guilty about it
just the fact that you guys would
combine finances when you get married
and you are going to take you guys
backwards is that it right yeah and um
he does have like a much larger income
than i do
and so i just would hate for there to be
any like resentment or animosity about
um me bringing in debt when he
doesn't have any has he
kind of alluded to that is that a little
bit of kind of his immo or is that are
you
playing that tape in your head just out
of yourself probably more of the latter
yeah he's never eluded
dakota how old are you
i am 26. okay
um
this guy's in love with you
you have a baby with him you sleep with
him you live with him
and you're trying to figure out how to
combine incomes
and combine everything but do all of
that without combining the debt
too late
that ship has sailed
rachel's right
i'm gonna put my old man
arm around you and give you a hug
and say honey
best thing for that baby
best thing for this man
best thing for you is get married and
then combine your incomes combine your
lives combine everything
join it together so tight that it cannot
be torn asunder and then go live a
beautiful glorious life
okay and getting out of debt is part of
the adventure raising the child as part
of the adventure
uh waking up and looking at him when he
starts to lose his hair is part of the
adventure
okay
all right awesome well thank you all so
much for your help and then see here's
the problem it's legally and
relationally very difficult
to financially play house
when you're not married
because you get into this argument over
the mustard
who bought the mustard and yet you're in
the same bed it's just it's it's so
inconsistent and incongruent it's just
weird and awkward and that's just a part
of the the system that you're using is
all and it's not a judgment thing you
didn't hear judgment in our voices we
just want good things for you we love
you we love you and we love that baby
and we want you guys to have a wonderful
life
and so
um i i i would uh
take that tape out of your head and i
would wad it up and throw it away that
somehow you've done
something wrong by bringing the debt to
the table for god's sakes baby is a ten
debt is a one on a scale of one to ten
okay
relationships
is a small thing if you're both in
agreement that that this debt is a bad
thing and we're going to clear it as
fast as we can using all of our combined
marital incomes and assets and so that
we can have a wonderful glorious life
for this baby and as a couple then
you're gonna knock that dead out so fast
it's silly and
uh it's blocking you from having your
best possible wonderful glorious life
yeah it's hard to work as a team when
you're legally not a team and you're
having to go around all this stuff so
it's just hard
it's hard it's hard to do finances with
your roommate
it just is it's just it's it's yeah you
know you can't act like you're married
with your finances
when you're acting like you're married
with every other part of your life it's
just it's so awkward and weird and it's
hard and i'm not saying you're awkward
and weird i'm just saying this is the
way it works it's very difficult hey
thanks for the call very very good
question
you know a lot of people uh
living together that aren't married have
that exact question we've had it over
the years a lot um the other issue is is
that there's all kinds of data out there
in the world and this is not for dakota
but this is just generally on this
discussion
that
um they call it the poverty cycle or the
poverty indicators
the that that there's about three or
four poverty indicators that if you get
if you have a baby before you're married
again not not messing with dakota here
but i'm just giving you the poverty
poverty indicators uh if you um
get married before graduating from high
school
or uh or start living with someone
before you graduate from high school uh
if um you know and we keep going on the
levels of education all these different
things all of these things are
indicators
that that you know you're 90 more likely
i have to pull the study up i can't
remember the details but you're 90 more
likely to live before the poverty level
below the poverty level if you don't do
these things that are really social
indicators of what's going on in your
life because what happens is it's very
difficult to prosper for financially
when you're 17 years old with a baby
yeah well for sure yeah but i think even
more than that the stuff that i've seen
in research within the marriage aspect
of the rate of divorce is higher of
those that live together yeah so for me
i'm like you know there's there's a um
probably a spiritual conviction that
that we have with this but they're also
after over the years of seeing people do
this like you said just kind of playing
house
there's a commitment level there in a
marriage that has to be there um and it
affects your outcome financially yes and
when it's not there right and that's
what i'm saying is like the the
tentacles play in it's just like when
people come in with a with a marriage
a money question about marriage so well
my spouse won't get on the same page the
tentacles are just the money but there's
so much underneath that and so pressing
this generation it sounds great oh well
i'll see if we like each other enough to
live together the living together is a
small portion of it it is it's the
marriage commitment that you that that
is the greatest weight and that weight
has been taken away from this generation
is what it feels like to me yeah yeah
it's now you're sounding like an old
person
from this generation
i worry about this generation for 12
years don't worry about the generations
unbelievable those are ginseers oh
little puppies oh god bless them
this is the ramsay show